bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france est-ce que la contamination de
donald trump
kovy 10,9 à peser sur le débat de ce
soir est éclipsé les autres grandes
thématiques de cette campagne électorale
les éclipses et peut-être pas parce que
le débat ce apprentis cote ont pesé en
revanche c'est plus que peser c'est à
dire que ça envahi l'esprit public étant
donné que non seulement la présidence
est touché mais aussi d'autres hauts
responsables soient politiques soient
des ministères et pas des moindres comme
le ministère de la défense aux états
unis et donc il ya évidemment une marque
majeure sur cette situation très
particulière décidément effet cette
élection sera bien singulière compte
tenu du contexte sanitaire économique et
de la personnalité du président sortant
de l'âge des deux candidats et la
plupart d'ailleurs des responsables
politiques la question est de savoir
s'ils ont trop bas j'ai calé
fragilisation du pouvoir introduit le
virus un pays
gergy un petit peu la question mais dans
un pays où peut-être beaucoup d'aspect
assez important du fonctionnement
constitutionnel et institutionnel la
désignation grands électeurs le rôle du
sénat
la désignation des sénateurs et c'est
tout ceci pose question depuis bien
longtemps à ce que cette crise par
exemple pourrait servir de vecteur à une
réforme institutionnelle aux états unis
j'en doute mais en tout cas la question
est posée par exemple dans ça va assez
loin
donc c'est plus que peser c'est comme je
vous le disais envahir l'esprit public
et pourrait soulever des questions qui
sont latentes depuis longtemps donald
trump est en difficulté aujourd'hui quel
est l'impact de sa contamination aux
côtés des deux sauts sa campagne
c'est difficile à dire en termes
quantitatifs et de décision des
électeurs je ne pense pas que ça lui
serve même s'il devait y avoir comme ça
semble être le cas un robe le fait qu'il
est terrassé le virus et que donc il
était un petit peu comme toujours
confiance en lui
ce que ça raffermissent abbas est
possible lui faire gagner des voix jean
douceur et la situation actuelle montre
que même si elle est stable tchoubaïs
dogues maintient son avance y compris
dans les états clés son état de
naissance comme la pennsylvanie qu'un
matin de la floride et d'autres encore
donc évidemment il ya beaucoup
d'incertitudes sur cette élection non il
suffit de suivre l'actualité
elle est assez spectaculaire mais pour
l'instant rien ne renversent si je puis
dire la vapeur de manière marquante
faveur du président sortant
on imagine aussi que sera abordé ce soir
la communication désastreuse qui a été
fait autour de ces premiers jours de
contamination notamment par ses médecins
qui ont dit une chose puis son contraire
naturellement cela après plutôt le flanc
aux accusations en dénonciations ont 10
ans du style trump à savoir bas nylon
colporter de fausses nouvelles
inventer les réalités le voir même des
chiffres ça fait partie du manque de
sincérité et de transparence et le
sérieux de fond qui est attachée à son
style
alors qu'il a pu avant qu'il exerce le
pouvoir convaincre il a été élu en 2016
il est parfaitement légitime
même s'il a perdu au vote populaire ce
n'est pas le premier dans ce cas
aujourd'hui en revanche ces aspects là
sur des sujets qui touchent l'ensemble
des américains quand les conséquences
la crise sanitaire
très proches pour leur travail leur
situation familiale leur situation
sociale on va évidemment la chose de
bien peut-être plus en plus gênante et
donc une fois de plus c'est un élément
de plus qui me fait dire que je ne vois
pas quels bénéfices évidents elle
pourrait tirer de sa situation même si
on souhaite évidemment comme cela semble
être le cas à titre personnel qu'il se
remette de ses de ceux de cet avis
savoir ce sont les colistiers qui
s'affronteront l'autre grand rendez vous
est attendu le 15 octobre entre joe
biden et donald trump donald trump on le
rappelle est toujours malade ducobu 19
est ce que on peut envisager
l'annulation de ce débat du 15 octobre
quand un donald trump reprendra t'il
réellement la campagne il l'est déjà
reprise mais sur twitter
oui il sort à agir sur les réseaux
sociaux la différence est que jordan lui
qui a fait déjà plusieurs tests n'est
pas positif est qu'il peut c'est le sens
si j'ai bien compris de sa campagne il
aurait tort de s'en priver
continuer à mener une campagne physique
avec des réunions évidemment comme dans
toute réunion publique aujourd'hui à
travers le monde pour l'essentiel mesure
est codifié quadrillé mais qui lui
permet toujours d'aller convaincre
d'aller au contact puisque tout en pagne
électorale dans un pays représentatifs
c'est c'est quand même la clé c'est
quand même inévitable c'est là où on
prend le pouls de l'opinion et ou
peut-être d'ailleurs un candidat peut
corriger les erreurs de tir
ce sera plus compliqué sans doute pour
des mannequins qu'il a été assez
critique et d'ailleurs pour sa sortie
même dans une voiture il y a
jour de l'hôpital pour saluer quelques
supporters lorsque vous avez raison de
souligner l'importance du débat des
colistiers de ce soir kamala harris et
vice-président pence ce sera sans doute
un des plus importants ce que de l'année
débat de politique aurait plus de relief
un contenu la situation les candidats
eux-mêmes convient de commenter assez
largement maintenant deux peut-être
aussi pour découvrir les personnalités
de l'ain et surtout de l'autre la
colistière de joe biden pour deux
raisons la première c'est qu'elle est
assez peu connu la seconde c'est que si
monsieur byden gagne ya de très fortes
chances de lui succéder avant terme ou
après son terme et la troisième c'est
parce que disons que le la tonalité de
leurs échanges après le désastre débat
entre les candidats eux-mêmes pourrait
être un indicateur au fond pour certains
électeurs indécis je pense que ce
débat-là des vice-présidents des
candidats à la vice-présidence sera sans
doute un des plus importants qu'on ait
vu depuis longtemps
au cours des dernières des dernières
sélections qui pourrait-on pas être
déterminant mais peser pour le coup
reprendre votre terme sur l'état
d'esprit des électeurs et nous suivrons
ce débat ce soir merci à yannick mireur
politologue spécialiste des états unis